wow all right everybody get ready
store is set to open in exactly one
minute 60
59. you don't have to say all the
numbers 60
61. yeah that's right i'm going up now
okay one last thought before we open
that
yes you can get pregnant from that ankle
you can get pregnant from any angle what
no i can't i can't hear you
if i could just get everybody describing
what black friday means to them that
would be
kate that's a new camera attention
cloud9 shoppers apparently black friday
has begun
from all of us here at cloud9 have a
great purge
[Music]
okay fine sal and i are having sex in
the dressing rooms
oh ugh i don't even like him i have
self-esteem issues and i think being
with him is a way of me punishing myself
it's messed up shut up sandra god you're
such a whiner sit down
[Applause]
wow it's a big cheering section okay
that's congordzol from mongolia
she grew up in a hut that was entirely
made of ice and mud
then she became their mayor then their
police chief and their best wolverine
wrangler
i love her so you're from mongolia
theme will you take me with you and you
go back there
oh we i love you
did you understand that did you bring
any wolverines i don't know that they
were never unicorns
i read that we discover like 50 new
species of frogs each year
maybe scientists just haven't discovered
unicorns frogs are tiny i think somebody
would have noticed a unicorn a lot of
people believe unicorns exist a lot of
people believe in bigfoot a lot of
people believe in angels
i believe in angels no you don't yeah i
do
i used to think kangaroos were real oh
how'd you do that dude come on throw
that one back it's too small
it's enormous but it's mine you perv
peter why do you live here
because the room opened up when scrote's
dad died and he became the king of
kuwait
oh
it's totally slanted they're just
pushing the pro-business anti-worker
candidates
what a corporation doing something
unethical to protect his interest
this is shocking is that what's
happening here
oh yo yeah we found this bird outside we
tried to turn it into a work whistle
like in the beginning of the flintstones
tougher than it looked though shame this
store doesn't have a colleen i will burn
my face off if she takes my job
i just mean nobody's even trying because
nobody cares about beating some random
store locations on a scoreboard
people need a nemesis to compete against
so what are you saying if we start
trash talking bellridge that's gonna
inspire people maybe
all the best wars are fought against
someone and that feels random all wars
are fought against someone yeah that's
what i'm saying no i'm saying
all wars yeah all the best wars what are
the best wars
1812 ww1 ww2 french indy
although if they started trash talking
us first okay what
wars are you not fighting against
someone war against poverty war against
drugs
boom don't come at me come on there you
are
they know about you what if they saw
your picture they know what you look
like we have to go now okay
where do we go i don't know oh my god oh
my god oh my god okay listen to me very
carefully i'll get you out of there
uh repeat you've got agents coming your
way from men's wear and electronics make
a left at aisle nine and we'll lose them
in grocery
thank you dina go now you're gonna find
yourself in a situation
where you're dating a girl and you
realize she's like an immigrant or
whatever
and you gotta choose between your love
and your country
hasn't come up oh you choose love though
yeah i can tell i know you're tight
okay keep walking come on all right when
you hit the end of the aisle you're
gonna need to head due
west left or right tina left new
restaurants diy going through the store
from camping to customer service how do
you not know that
left okay
hey oh oh oh there's someone run come on
come on come on
so everyone knows now everyone knows
do you want to get married
okay
okay you guys need to keep going
straight through the beauty and we're
gonna try to make it all the way to the
end of the dark section all right let's
go
go go go
go go did you know that the capital of
panama is panama
i can rap the entire central american
countries i did it once for a talent
competition
mexico de fe mexico guatemala guatemala
cigalpa honduras san salvador el
salvador san jose
costa rica panama
stop stop reverse course turn around
okay uh new plan uh just make it to
pharmacy you can hide them
no no wait turn around turn around go
back go back the other way
uh you could lose some housewares i
think just book it okay book it to the
end this one go down here
stop stop no wait stop there's like 20
guys coming that way
stop stop stop no there's another one
there's no hold on hold on dude
just tell us where to go okay hang on
just wait wait
i i don't i don't know
they're everywhere what i'm sorry
no um okay there's a vent up there we
can
climb up on the thing and we'll go
create a diversion and take off our tops
while you go run yeah let's do that okay
stop stop guys it's okay
it's over
[Music]
i mean we have to fight this how
uh no idea
okay what if someone steals a baby what
then do you want me to just sit there
and watch someone take a baby what if
the baby is wearing a bomb then wouldn't
you want him to steal it
i'm trying to picture a scenario in
which somebody plays oh what if it's
baby hitler
a very good question tough is it i think
you gotta kill that baby hitler yeah
how would you know that that baby was
going to grow up to be hitler what if
that baby was going to grow up to be the
exact opposite of hitler
churchill no lance bass interesting
oprah yeah oprah oprah you got to save
that baby got to save
it i'm more of an ellen person
it's fun when she dances anyway what i'm
saying is
don't be adina be a jonah
oh wait you guys what if
it's baby oprah but the person stealing
it is beyonce
jonah you think i'm doing it wrong but
if we stack them five wide and low
they're less prone to toppling me
what's wrong they fired glenn what yeah
so um about that walkout
mateo clint got fired we're walking out
are you coming
sorry i was doing a teal and green story
here
all the employees are leaving early
because they're staging a walkout
uh because glenn got fired sure man that
[Music]
works
you still have i credit card hello
[Music]
oh no no you guys do not have to do this
okay you know what i understand that
you're upset about glenn
i i know and i get that no no no come on
corporate cares
oh sure glands drink yourself to a brand
new car
just as what's job's going great what
could possibly go
wrong
is this gonna work i don't know
it's worth a shot right so
what now
you